members of the squad exploding with rage
after congresswoman Ilan Omar got voted
off The Foreign Affairs committee the
progressive Representatives saying that
racism is why Republicans removed Omar
and not her history of anti-semitic
remarks
Omar um
has expired
the gentleman is no longer Republicans
are waging a blatantly
islamophobic and racist attack on
congresswoman Omar and I've said it
before I will say it again the white
supremacy happening is unbelievable this
is about targeting women of color in the
in the United States of America don't
tell me because I didn't get a single a
time has expired my life was threatened
thank you
hmm Omar insists that being kicked off
the committee will not silence her
my leadership and voice will not be
diminished
if I am not on this committee for one
term my voice will get louder and
stronger and my leadership will be
celebrated around the world as it has
been and AOC later escalating her
attacks on Republicans for this move
it's uncomfortable
um serving with people who engage in
what many experts deem stochastic
terrorism I've had consistently had to
ride in 20 000 pound armored vehicles in
um in you know engaging in some of the
most gruesome threats that you can
imagine that were incited by Republican
members
okay
um Harold let's start with you Rashida
Talib said that the country's failing
her doing what it is best at weaponizing
hate against a black beautiful Muslim
woman is this what's happening here so
I've said for a while I think that that
the back and forth between the parties
um and and payback uh will never stop if
someone doesn't become an adult in the
room offensive language and behavior in
politics if that's the standard for not
being able to serve on a committee there
would not be many many people but not be
serving on committees uh into Congress
because someone always deemed someone's
language as offensive or they're they're
opposing it
uh two
um I don't I don't see that the racial
part of it is not something I see I I'm
quick to point out race when I think
race is an issue but I think here uh
Democrats uh were guilty in the Congress
before and taking off one or two
Republicans because they didn't like
their language they didn't like their
words
um I think the words of Marjorie Taylor
green others I found uh offensive and I
found deeply disturbing but I'm an
old-fashioned guy when it comes to
politics I think the way you defeat
someone in politics is you actually
defeat them in politics you defeat them
at the election uh and unless you do
something that violates the standards of
the house and their rules around if you
get indicted you can't serve on a
committee or your committee membership
or standing is in Peril or in question
but in this sense I just I don't
understand it and I hope at some point
um that with that that adult-like
behavior comes back uh because if
Democrats win this win the majority in
24 26 or whenever they win it they'll
win it again
um we're going to have this same kind of
thing happen probably and I just hope
and pray that adults in adult Behavior
Uh emerges again in the Congress what do
you say to that I mean it does there
come a point where people say look I
totally disagree with Omar and I think
her she should be you know she's
basically being canceled for
anti-semitic remarks right that's what's
happened here look let's be clear on
this the Democrats did it and you know I
think the criticism should have come
when the Democrats did it because we
told them good we told them that they're
establishing the precedent okay you
establish the president what's good for
the goose is good for Gander but what I
find Most Fascinating about this is that
like Rashida Talib is saying she's a
black beautiful woman she's in Islam
woman
intersectionality is not a defense
that you can use to every argument that
someone makes she was taken off because
they had to pass a congressional
resolution because of her attacks on on
Israel and Jews the Benjamins and all
the other stuff and supporting BDS which
is a state department to find active
anti-Semitism you know so we're talking
about an ally of the United States and
she has crossed the line many times so
this has nothing to do with her color it
has nothing to do with the religion if
that were the case Maxine Waters
wouldn't be sitting on committees okay
so let's make it clear what this is
about this is about a woman who has
displayed behavior that people believe
she shouldn't be on the Foreign Affairs
committee and she shouldn't have that
kind of information and you know no
intersectionality argument is a defense
to that so Jesse Kevin McCarthy says
that he's going to form a bipartisan
group to create a house code of conduct
so that there's agreement on these kinds
of things when people are potentially
going to be removed from committees for
their actions that sounds like a good
idea to me I like that I'm with the
judge race is now such a Dodge
it's not about the issues it's just
about race
I'm terrible at math but I think I can
handle this if two white guys got kicked
off committee Schiff and swallow well
then she was treated just like the two
white guys why is it about race with her
but it's not about race with these guys
shifted and say oh I'm getting kicked
off because I'm Jewish
he could have said that swallows I I got
kicked off because I'm short you could
always use something that has nothing to
do with the issue to make yourself more
of a victim and the fact that Omar had
her staff go to Kinkos and blow up a
photograph of herself as a young girl
life-size and put it next to herself
while she spoke on the house floor the
ego to do that I would not do that
Donald Trump would not do that Greg
Gutfeld would never do that although the
placard would be smaller it takes a
certain type of ego to speak in front of
a large life-size pictures of yourself
and make it all about her it was all
about her and have you ever heard the
squad that upset when their constituents
get shot
when one of their constituents gets
shoved into a Subway track when someone
ODS from Cartel fentanyl they never get
upset they got this upset when one of
their squad members got removed from a
committee and that tells you it's all
about them that has nothing to do with
us the voters yeah and it's all about
her gender and her skin color and her
religion yeah and yeah I mean she was
booted from a foreign affairs committee
but to be honest she'd be better on the
family Affairs committee she is the
luckiest person in America she is a
refugee who was able to use the
generosity of this system and the
tolerance and the open-mindedness of the
American public to live above the rules
the the case in point is I'm I make this
joke I've been making this joke for I
don't know how long about her husband
and her brother
do they ever respond they don't have to
could you imagine if there was a strong
not uh debunked rumor not even a rumor
assumption that a republican married a
sibling
where the Washington Post oh democracy
would die in the darkness if we didn't
cover that but in this case it's like
you know you can make a joke about it
nobody even like it's just like yeah
yeah we get it too bad so what you know
but going back to what the judge said
you know she voted against people like
Marjorie Taylor green and ghosts are and
then if you look at the January sex
committee where basically they picked
and choose the the team so if you're
gonna make a d if you're gonna do that
and the goose the goose Gander argument
I've said it before classified documents
probably didn't mean anything uh for
Trump or for Biden but they made a big
deal about it and the only way you can
teach Democrats a lesson is to give it
to give it back to them I don't like
that strategy but the fact is it's the
only way to get them to stop making big
deals out of stupid things this is a
trend that happened with Trump the
inclination now is to Fight Fire with
Fire uh this might be only the only way
to get certain Democrats to behave
because turning the other Chic all that
all you end up with is with a bruised
butt and that's all you have to impeach
Joe Button exactly impeach him now
equity
doesn't go on forever hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else